bon alors oui on va faire une interview
maintenant on va baisser la lumière à 9h
toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
voilà c'est ma joie
ça il ya le sampler aussi tiens je vais
vous mettre
pas une mauvaise nuit à la croisière
s'amuse c'est agréable
la chanson tout est rose et
sa j'adore quand je suis à mon sport mon
prof de gym branchez mon sport il mais
ça sinon sa mémoire
bon alors lihau vous avez dit vous avez
déclaré
c'est bizarre j'ai toujours été une
femme seule j'étais accompagné
finalement très peu de temps et j'ai eu
mes enfants avec des hommes différents
ma célébrité finalement est un énorme
problème dans ma vie sentimentale est ce
que vous pensez vraiment que si vous
n'aviez été je ne vais pas été liées ou
si vous étiez resté wanda est ce que
vous auriez moins de problèmes avec les
hommes oui pourquoi
parce que c'est très difficile de se
retrouver à un moment donné
comme étant monsieur lio et moi je n'ai
entendu ça des gens qui venaient qui
présentait mais mes hommes comme
monsieur lio est en fait moi je trouvais
c'était ridicule de la part des autres
mais eux petit à petit au v ridicule de
ma part d'être lio mais c'était dommage
parce que je l'étais avant je ne pouvais
pas arrêter tout d'un coup c'était
maintenant c'est comme une seconde
nature lio et ça a posé des problèmes
mais ça pose des problèmes je mets un
problème de gagner plus que son ami bon
alors c'est vrai alors donc voila moi
j'ai fait le compte quand même là lieu
lui dire d'abord c'est marrant on trouve
normal par contre de dieu là dans ma
chambre on s'en fout pas bougé
on s'est suffisamment chamailler sur des
plateaux pour que je puisse vous faire
un compliment sincère je vous trouve
très belle en ce moment là présentement
les âmes ainsi très joli vous êtes bien
une belle robe vous êtes des belles nat
et j'adore les brunes et vous avez du
rouge à lèvres un peu rouge ça ça me
plait sa mère béatrice je te le dis si
tu pouvais mettre le même genre de rouge
à lèvres que liu ça me ferait plaisir
vol
bon allez maintenant à moi je suis là
vraiment
les du sud c'est normal une portugaise
c'est un ça le fait un renault avec
ortega show la
star fait le deuil des choses pas bon
étudier aussi
bon alors j'ai compté les hommes
s'est pas encore gloria lasso mais quand
même c'est sur la route 1 c'est-à-dire
il ya eu d'abord votre premier
duval il faut bien prendre le parolier
qu'on adore tous ben voilà faisait 13
ans et demi oui
ensuite il ya eu estévenens notre ami
est et ben qui vous avez qui vous est
venue bien oui ensuite j'ai eu patrick
alexis
avec qui vous a eu deux enfants igor et
smeralda content on est déjà un deux
trois oui non attendez
non maintenant 1 2 3 4 zad le dernier en
date je vais y aller qui vous avez des
jumelles voient là un grand coup photo
ac pas beaucoup mais non ah bon mais je
suis vieux juillet les enfants à chaque
fois à l'espagne 5 en format non c'est
d'ailleurs lui ou avec
c'est vrai lio c'est je le sais moi je
vous ai vu à l'été nubia sur les
plateaux il ya aux bains douches alors
vous avez déclaré mon ami hugo pratt
mais elle est pourtant conseillé de ne
pas tuer le désirent dans ce milieu
avides de chair fraîche personne ne veut
d'une fille avec cinq gosses aux basques
vous pensez que ça vous handicape
aujourd'hui tous ces enfants mois 6 mois
sam handicap un sujet
microsphères à moi ça mon handicap pas
au contraire dans ma vie de femme sait
quelque chose
de génial mais ça ça handicape dans mon
travail mais oui bien sûr sam handicap
dans mon travail parce que c'est c'est
pas de trouver des gens en général les
femmes veulent bien travaillé avec moi
mais derrière une femme réalisatrice il
ya toujours un homme producteurs et
l'homme producteur lui n'a pas envie
d'une artiste à problèmes entre
guillemets c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
pourrait éventuellement lui refusé de
lui donner la 200e heures
supplémentaires gratos puisque c'est
maintenant ce qu'on vous demande moi
depuis que j'ai commencé à tourner mes
cachets ont été divisés par 3 voire 4
toujours soi disant pour des problèmes
de cinéma français qui ne marche pas
mais j'ai toujours vu les producteurs
avec la même des mw et les mêmes
costumes cerruti donc donc vous voulez
je trouve que c'est comme un nouvel
esclavage isme parce que comme on manque
de boulot c'est difficile pour tout le
monde donc on commence à dire aux
techniciens faut diviser vos prix et
puis si c'est pas vous qui
voit là et donc ça c'est effectivement
et donc il ya autre chose qui chauffe
c'est quand tout d'un coup des
producteurs ont le choix entre lio est
une autre et une autre brune pas trop
grosse ils vont prendre peut-être
l'autre brune joli mais qui a pas cinq
enfants et moi je vais être éliminés sur
ce critère immédiatement oui mais c'est
la vérité je n'ai pas vraiment alonso
est pas là dites moi aimons tous les cas
pour une fille qui a eu cinq enfants
c'est vachement bien
pour une fille qui n'a plus être en
france j'ai commencé j'avais pas cinq
enfants ça serait énorme pour une
séquence de cinq enfants je me sens bien
je m'en vais conserver une presque 40
ans c'est vrai comment vous faites je
veux baez
ces tarifs étaient volés en mon nom mais
alors vraiment non michel me connaissez
je vais à l'étranger schiste alors vous
vous disiez donc là vous avez des
problèmes avec votre jules actuelle et
pourtant vous disiez je crois que j'ai
trouvé ce que je cherchais je suis une
butineuse il me faut un vrai appel pour
m'arrêter avec lui il ya eu une vraie
osmose comment ça se fait que ce soit
terminé aussi mal après cette vraie
osmose ah mais ça je me serais toujours
la question que je continue à me poser
qui me pose c'est que des sacrés
problèmes
je ne sais pas c'est toujours cette
question quand ça se termine mais c'est
pas un an vous aviez l'air d'être
tellement d'avoir enfin trouvé mais je
suis très amoureuse de lui toujours oui
mais je ne veux plus jamais vivre avec
lui vous allez vous revoir quand même
nous on n'a pas le droit bon vous êtes
un peu disputées - pas là pour dire ça
dont il a quand même pris deux mois
ferme oui oui oui mais moi j'ai pris un
et cassé ouais d'accord vous n'êtes pas
porter visite j'ai pas porté plainte par
vengeance j'ai quand même un peu porter
plainte si l'on n'a pas pris deux mois
ferme j'ai un petit test parce que quand
on porte plainte c'est qu'on n'a pas
d'autre solution quand on essaye de
régler des problèmes
comme on peut avec ses moyens mais qu'à
un moment donné on va d'échec en échec
et de violent sans violence eh bien on
s'en refaire à la justice c'est pas que
je trouve ça formidable mais c'est que
je n'avais pas d'autre solution la
justice représente le père
c'est une autorité à laquelle on s'en
remet quand on reconnaît notre échec
notre échec à nous de résoudre le
problème voilà mieux vous avez dit que
vous jugiez la sanction un peu sévère là
les six mois fait les six mois de prison
n'ont jamais dit ça je ne je ne suis pas
a priori pour la prison parce que je
trouve que c'était pas là qu'on résout
les les problèmes mais
mais les deux mois ferme n'était qu'une
partie de la sentence et moi j'avais
besoin de protection et gelé obtenus et
la justice a fait des grands pas pour
les femmes battues il fallait qu'elle
les fasse parce qu'on est vraiment seul
dans ces cas là et surtout vous êtes
toujours coupable mois la plupart des
hommes qui m'ont parlé depuis n'ont pas
du tout le sentiment de s'adresser à une
victime mais c'est comme les femmes
victimes d'un violent c'est que je les
bien cherché comme en plus on le monde
sait que c'est un sale caractère on se
dit que vraiment j'ai dû torturé ce
pauvre homme c'est quand même moi qui
avait le nez cassé et le une entorse
cervicale et quatre vertèbres déplacées
qu'on a dû remettre le les folies
bergères et que ça a été terrible et que
je m'en remets toujours pas moi en tout
cas sûr ça ne se voit pas et sur scène
ça se voit pas mais ça c'est la magie du
spectacle sur scène oui alors vous
flippez un peu sur votre âge ce que
quand on vous voit on a du mal à
comprendre franchement ou dit liu c'est
pas moi je la met en scène tous les
jours elles existent palio j'ai fait un
sale coup à lier aux gésiers le messager
nous disait il ya dix ans déjà de ça
parce que c'est vrai lyon était la
représentation de l'adolescence elle
avait entre 12 et 14 ans quand je les
choisis c'était mon âge à l'époque dans
une bd de de jean claude forest et elle
était le symbole de l'adolescente oui et
c'est vrai que je ne suis plus le
symbole de l'adolescente avec cinq
enfants je suis respecté
ces adolescentes à 50 ans et au ghana
oui est-ce que vous je ne critique pas
le ghana je tiens à le dire je veux pas
d'histoires je ne critique pas le ghana
est ce que vous avez vous dites j'ai du
mal à me voir vieillir j'ai la mécanique
s'affaiblit ce n'est jamais très
agréable
oui c'est vrai et c'est jamais très
agréable de voir les leurs les regards
des hommes toujours attiré par la
jeunesse mais moi vous êtes très
attirante mais vous êtes une femme dans
la plénitude la wii non il faut pas
flipper l'aller au nom peut-être cci
comme ça c'est sans doute une étape
obligée du succès très jeune avec un
personnage de lolita effectivement
banana split et tout ça mais quand on
vous voit là écouter thierry moi je
crois une chose je crois que on se voit
énormément dans le regard que l'homme
que vous aimez portent sur vous et je
crois que quand le regard qu'on reçoit
est quelque chose qui vous a faibli
qu'yves qui vous remettent tellement en
question et sur des choses qui sans
doute sont ridicules moi je trouve ça
une perte d'énergie totale mais la
vérité est que samassa marca des choses
qui m'ont marqué c'est vrai que je me
regarde plus dans la glace avec la même
le même la même désinvolture disons
parce que moi je ne me suis jamais
regarder dans la glace avec attention
j'étais désinvolte et je la perds au
port et c'est une peur qui vient alors
je m'en demandez tourner très vite mais
je crois que je crois que c'est sale
tout simplement je crois qu'on ne
vieillit jamais quand les gens mais vous
ces gens là trois mois je peux vous dire
que j'ai bien plus âgée que vous
problème c'est que dans la tête on vit
pas vraiment mais le corps vie et puis
après les gens les gens n'y croient pas
quand on dit ça on vous dit quand même
j'ai hâte d'être une vieille dame
indigne
vais te passer le cadre de l' entre deux
mois jamais mais avant le cul entre deux
êtres
on y voit un vrai c'est vrai qu'on a
envie à un moment de se dire ouais
rafinha un moment on se dit la
vieillesse il faut que ça serve à ne
plus en avoir à [ __ ] de rien
au moins cet avantage là c'est ça et de
pouvoir faire plein de conneries et puis
personne venu venir vous dire quelle
conne ça c'est génial sincèrement que
j'attends avec manu merci et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu